perfecto estamos ahora en el problema 5
en la página 408 y tenemos este pequeño
dibujo aquí y nos dicen que en el disco
mostrado a continuación un jugador hace
girar la flecha dos veces así que
tenemos esta flecha y la vamos a hacer
girar en este disco dos veces y con esto
vamos a formar la fracción a / b así que
vamos a notarlo aquí vamos a formar la
fracción am / b donde a va a ser el
número que marque el sector en el cual
se detuvo la flecha en la primera vez
que se giró es decir vamos a girar la
flecha va a dar vueltas y vueltas y
vueltas y se va a parar en un sector y
en el sector que se pare nos vamos a
fijar en qué número cayó qué número está
en este sector para que así tome ese
valor de ese número
así que am va a salir de nuestro primer
giro primer giro después b va a ser el
número que marque el sector
en el cual se detuvo la flecha en la
segunda vez que se giró así que otra vez
vamos a girar la flecha y en donde se
detenga la flecha nos vamos a fijar en
este número y ese va a ser nuestro valor
de bebé entonces en nuestro segundo giro
muy bien ya tenemos quien es a quien nos
ven y después que nos pregunten a
esperar a que la nota todos los sectores
tienen la misma probabilidad de que la
flecha se detenga en ese sector cuál es
la probabilidad de que la fracción entre
b sea mayor que 1 es decir yo lo que
quiero es que la probabilidad de a entre
b si hacemos esta fracción este número
sea más grande que 1 y bueno lo primero
que quiero decirte es que esto es
equivalente a un generador de números
aleatorios
es decir la probabilidad de que el
número que nos salga sea uno de estos
seis es la misma o dicho de otra manera
esto es lo mismo que aventar a un dado
de seis caras iguales y entonces el
problema lo podríamos pensar como
aventar un mismo dado dos veces seguidas
y lo que buscaríamos sería la
probabilidad de que el número del primer
tiro sea mayor que el número del segundo
tiro no es así para que esta fracción
entre b sea mayor que 1 entonces am
tiene que ser mayor que vemos o
inclusive esto lo podemos ver de la
siguiente manera esto es exactamente lo
mismo que calcular la probabilidad de
que a sea mayor que b
si yo multiplico por b ambos lados de
esta desigualdad es decir realmente lo
que estamos buscando es que el número
que no salga en nuestro primer tiro sea
más grande que el número que no salga en
nuestro segundo tiro así que si vamos a
hablar de dos tiros vamos a ponerlos
aquí la primera vez que giramos esta
flecha el primer giro y bueno en el
primer giro que nos puede salir si te
das cuenta nos puede salir pues 1 2 3 4
5 6 entonces vamos a ponerlo aquí en
nuestro giro 1 nos puede salir 1 nos
puede salir 2 nos puede salir 3 nos
puede salir 4 5 nos puede salir
y ahora si yo lo que quiero calcular es
la probabilidad de que nos salga uno de
estos números en el primer giro cuánto
va a ser la probabilidad del giro 1
bueno pues como nos dice la nota que la
probabilidad de que caiga la flecha en
cualquiera de estos sectores es la misma
y tenemos 6 sectores entonces la
probabilidad que nos salga 1 en el
primer giro pues es un sexto de que no
salga 2 en el primer giro pues en la
misma es un sexto la probabilidad de que
no salga 3 también va a ser un sexto la
probabilidad de que no salga 4 es un
sexto de que no salga 5 es un sexto de
que no salga 6 es la misma un sexto que
por cierto con el giro 1 vamos a obtener
el valor de a recuerda que am sale del
primer giro así que vamos a notarlo aquí
para que no se nos olvide con el giro 1
vamos a obtener a y bueno esto es para
el giro 1 ahora si yo me fijo en el giro
2 vamos a pensar qué es lo que pasa
cuando yo
la probabilidad de que el número que me
salga en el giro 1 sea más grande que el
número que me salga en el giro 2 es
decir que am sea mayor que b justo
ahorita vamos a pensar en esta
probabilidad ahora voy a buscar la
probabilidad de que el número que nos
salga en el giro 2 sea más grande que lo
que nos salió en el giro 1 ya ver
analicemos un poquito si en el giro 1 me
salió 1 yo lo que voy a buscar en el
giro 2 es un número menor que 1 y si te
das cuenta no hay ningún número menor
que 1 por lo tanto la probabilidad de
obtener un número menor que 1 en el
segundo giro si en el primer giro me dio
1 pues es 0 a ver vamos a analizar qué
es lo que pasa si el giro 1 obtuvimos un
2 y en el giro 1 obtuvimos un 2 entonces
lo que voy a buscar en el giro 2 es un
número que sea más chico que 2 y si te
das cuenta el único número más chico que
2 que me pueda salir en el giro 2
1 porque si me sale tres o cuatro o
cinco o seis estos números son más
grandes que dos entonces no me serviría
y si me sale el dos mismo son iguales y
yo lo que quiero es un número menor el
único número menor que me puede salir en
mi giro 2 que sea menor que 2 es 1 por
lo tanto solamente tengo una
probabilidad de 6 posibles casos de seis
posibles números que me podrían salir
ahora vamos a fijarnos qué es lo que
pasa si en el giro 1 me sale un 3 yo lo
que voy a buscar es la probabilidad de
que en mi segundo giro obtenga un número
menor que 3 y qué números posibles tengo
menores que 3 para mi giro 2 bueno los
únicos números posibles es 1 y 2 todos
los demás son mayores o iguales que 3
por lo tanto de todos los casos
factibles solamente tengo dos sextos y
nosotros pensamos en el 4 en el giro 1
me salió 4 y entonces cuál es la
probabilidad de obtener en mi giro 2 un
número que sea menor que 4
los números que son menores que 4 en el
giro 2 son 3 2 1 por lo tanto solamente
tengo tres posibles opciones de los seis
tiros posibles que tengo esto si me sale
4 en el primer tiro si me sale 5 en mi
primer tiro pues vamos a ver cuáles son
los posibles números que sean menores
que 5 para que me salgan en el segundo
tiro y es 1234 por lo tanto la
probabilidad es 4 sextos y por último si
me sale 6 los números que son más chicos
que 6 que pueden ser factibles para mi
segundo giro son todos estos que tengo
aquí y entonces mi probabilidad son 5
sextos
esta es mi probabilidad de mi primer
tirón es la probabilidad de que en mi
segundo tiro obtenga algo más pequeño
que en mi primer tirón cuál va a ser mi
probabilidad total a ver vamos a
analizar la probabilidad de que en mi
primer tiro me salga uno de estos
números y que en mi segundo tiro me
salga un número menor cuál es esta
probabilidad pues lo que hay que hacer
es multiplicar estas dos probabilidades
que ya tengo esta probabilidad por esta
probabilidad es decir estoy calculando
la probabilidad de que me salga uno en
el primer tiro y que me salga un número
menor que uno en el segundo tiro un
sexto por cero es cero ahora cuál es la
probabilidad de que me salga 2 en el
primer tiro y además que obtenga un
número menor que 2 en el segundo tiro
pues es un sexto por un sexto lo cual me
da 1 sobre 36
ahora vamos a pensar en este número 3 la
probabilidad de obtener un 3 en el
primer tiro es un sexto y la
probabilidad de obtener un número menor
que 3 en el segundo tiro es dos sextos y
si lo multiplicó me da 2 sobre 36 y
ahora multiplicando estos dos de una
manera análoga me va a salir 3 sobre 36
y aquí 4 sobre 36 y por último aquí voy
a obtener 5 sobre 36 y ahora la
probabilidad total pues va a ser la suma
de todas estas probabilidades porque
estos son todos mis factibles casos de
que yo obtenga un número menor en el
segundo tiro que en el primer tiro y
cuánto es 1 sobre 36 más 2 sobre 36 más
3 sobre 36 4 sobre 36 más 53 sobre 36
bueno pues es uno dos tres más tres son
seis más cuatro son diez quince 15 sobre
15 sobre 36 es decir que la probabilidad
de que yo obtenga una fracción a / b que
sea mayor que 1 va a ser de 15 entre 36
esta es mi respuesta que por cierto es
el inciso a así que este problema estuvo
un poco pesado
espero no haberlo confundido mucho voy a
borrar este pizarrón muy bien y vamos a
poner aquí el problema número 6 y dice
cuáles de las siguientes tablas muestran
una relación proporcional y bueno aquí
tengo cuatro tablas que para no
copiarlas todas y tardar mucho vamos a
intentar copiar por aquí pegar por acá y
vamos a ver si pasan para acá las tablas
aquí están perfecto ya que tengo mis
cuatro opciones de tablas las cuales me
preguntan en cuál de estas tablas w es
proporcional a equis y recuerda que
cuando yo me refiero a que dos variables
son proporcionales esto quiere decir que
una
para llegar a la otra se tiene que
multiplicar siempre por la misma
constante a qué me refiero vamos a verlo
en esta primera tabla aquí cuando w le
uno para llegar a que x valga 3 hay que
multiplicarlo por 3
en esta primera fila multiplicamos por 3
y después en este caso de 2 a 4
tuvimos que multiplicar a 2 por 2 para
llegar a 4 y entonces aquí me habla
luego luego de que tenemos un
comportamiento que no es proporcional
cuando nosotros tenemos una tabla
proporcional
siempre estamos multiplicando por el
mismo factor y después aquí
multiplicamos por 5 tercios
entonces en definitiva esta no es mi
tabla que es proporcional entonces no es
el insisto vamos a ver qué pasa con el
inciso b
wv vale 3x vale 9 y 3 x 3
me dan 9 entonces aquí multiplicamos por
3 después aquí tengo 4 y el 4 cuando lo
llevamos al cuadrado media 16 si te das
cuenta esta es una tabla de cuadrados
3 al cuadrado 4 al cuadrado 5 al
cuadrado y en definitiva no es
proporcional porque porque aquí
multiplique por tres aquí voy a
multiplicar por cuatro para llegar al 16
multiplicó por 4 y aquí voy a
multiplicar por 5 y entonces no estoy
multiplicando por el mismo factor este
no es el mismo factor 3 4 y 5 y por lo
tanto el cis o b tampoco es vamos a ver
qué es lo que pasa con el inciso c el
ciso cd5 para llegar a 10 voy a
multiplicar por 2 aquí multiplicó por
dos y de seis para llegar a 18 no aquí
ya multiplique por tres no es el mismo
factor y por lo tanto tampoco es el
inciso c
vamos a ver mi inciso de 7 para llegar a
21 aquí multiplicó por 3 aquí vamos bien
8 para llegar a 24 multiplicó por 3
también multiplicó por 3 vamos a ver si
en la última también multiplicó por 3 9
por 3 27 es decir aquí siempre estoy
multiplicando por el mismo factor mi
factor es el 3 esto quiere decir que
están relacionadas estas dos variables
de un
de forma proporcional el cambio en una
de estas variables se resiente de una
misma manera en la otra variable así que
mi respuesta es el inciso de y bueno ya
no tengo tiempo en este vídeo así que
vamos a hacer más ejercicios en el
siguiente vídeo cuídate mucho